مع اشتداد القصف الاسرائيلي الجوي
والمدفعي على قطاع غزه توجه كتائب القسام
رسائلها لاسرائيل بشان مصير اسرها تحت
وابل القنابل والقذائف ومع انقشاع غبار
القصف ولو للحظات تتكشف فضائع لا يمكن
تخيلها مثل ما حصل مثلا في بيت لاهيه
عندما انتشل الدفاع المدني عشرات الجثث
المتحلله لمدنيين اعدموا ميدانيا وفي
جباليا كذلك تواصل القصف الاسرائيلي الذي
امتد الى حي الشيخ رضوان في مدينه غزه
وصولا الى المنطقه الوسطى وتحديدا مخيم
البريج ومخيم المغازي ودير البلح حيث سجل
سقوط عشرات الشهداء
والجرحى في الجنوب تحديدا في خان يونس
استهدف القصف الاسرائيلي منازل سكن مما
اسفر عن سقوط شهداء وجرحى كذلك في رافح
تحديدا تعرضت سياره مدنيه لقصف اسرائيلي
كذلك في التطورات الميدانيه اشتعلت محاور
التوغل من جباليا حيث تدور اشتباكات ضاريه
وفق القسام مما تسبب بمقتل واصابه عدد من
الجنود وتدمير دبابات بصواريخ اسرائيليه
لم تنفجر جرى استخدامها في الهجوم ششهد
نفسه يتكرر في جحر الديك وسط غزه حيث قالت
القسام انها استهدفت دبابات اسرائيليه في
كمين محكم مما اسفر عن مقتل واصابه الجنود
في المكان طبعا شراسه المعارك طالت ايضا
محاور شيخ رضوان
والشجاع في مدينه غزه في خان يونس اعلنت
كتائب القسام استدراج خمسه جنود من وحده
بلوم الى نفق شرق خانيونس
وتفجيره بعد دخولهم النفق والقضاء عليهم
من نقطه الصفر واضافت القسام ان مقاتليها
استهدفوا جنديين تحديدا جنديين اسرائيليين
بقذيفه ار بي جي في مدينه خانيونس مما ادى
الى مقتلهم على الفور وتحولهم الى
اشلا